When we're connected, it means we all believe in each other.
And I believe that you can do whatever you want, whenever you want.
So, do it.
I realized that I had a purpose, and it wasn't just about me.
Together, we can show the world how awesome it is to support one another...
...and build women up.
There is nothing more powerful than a group of determined sisters.
Let us fight with love.
When somebody underestimated me, it made me want to prove them wrong.
You know what, perfection isn't real.
You are great, don't worry about what anybody else thinks of you.
So many people around the world have a very negative idea...
...of what Muslim women are like.
It's pretty simple.
We're awesome.
I'm not a lone voice.
I am many.
I am Malala.
But I'm also Shazia.
I am Kainat.